2013 was always going to be a massive
year for playstation one way or another
by the time January rolled around all
eyes were on their hardware division the
playstation 3 had done well in 2012 but
the vita launch and subsequent first
holiday season was much less impressive
but all eyes were on the future and back
then rumors read the new playstation
were spreading like wild fires will it
really be called the Orbis are they
going to change the DualShock will it be
always online and come with some creepy
camera thing will there be a new parappa
the rappa as it turns out we wouldn't
have to wait too long for answers on
februari first sony announced that the
future playstation would be revealed in
new york in just 19 days and though they
didn't actually show us the machine they
did give us the first details on their
new console details such as it's called
the PlayStation 4 it has an x86
processor enhanced pc-style GPU and 8
gigabytes of unified gddr5 the
controller is the DualShock 4 it has a
crazy touchpad which likely nobody will
use you can upload footage of games
whenever you want you can stream your
game play live to the Internet's Gaikai
is a thing that's honest second screen
functionality with the Vita no backwards
compatibility and some games a new
Killzone new driving game that isn't
Gran Turismo and something called knack
once June rolled around III had all the
juicy details but while Microsoft had
pissed off at the gaming world but
confirmations that their new console
would be always online and have severe
restrictions on used games many assumed
Sony would go the same way but instead
Sony produced probably the biggest
gaming moment of the year while gamers
all around the world cheered in their
bedrooms too well let's just have
another watch shall we it's been a while
PlayStation 4 won't impose any new
restrictions on the use of people
you can trade in the game at retail sell
it to another person lend it to a friend
or keep it forever playstation 4
disc-based games don't need to be
connected online to play three hundred
and ninety-nine dollars oh and they
showed off the new console which looks
like a PlayStation 2 that's been
partially melted gorgeous we'd have to
wait until November to get our hands on
the new kit but it's easy to forget 2013
was also a massive year for the ps3 not
only did it have almost every hit that
the xbox 360 enjoyed but the ps3 also
had some wonderful exclusives The Last
of Us knee no kuni beyond two souls god
of war ascension dust 514 divekick
dragon's crown final fantasy 14 the
puppeteer ratchet and clank into the
Nexus and Sly Cooper thieves in time to
name just a few surprisingly the Vita
had a banger year to not only with some
fantastic new releases like the
wonderful tearaway but also with dozens
of great playing ports from the ps3 and
pc including hotline Miami stealth Inc
divekick guacamelee Rayman legends and
spelunky but apart from the games the
PlayStation 4 had breathed new life into
a handheld that previously looked to be
floundering remote play would allow you
to play ps4 games on your Vita even more
great deals to be had with cross by and
the continuing value of PlayStation Plus
while at the start of the year was
difficult to find many strong cases for
owning a Vita the handheld has been
rejuvenated these past 12 months and
looks to be a wonderful companion to the
ps4 going into 2014 and what about the
ps4 is PlayStation on its merry way to
regaining the console crown well on
November 15th in the US and on the 29th
in Europe the public finally had its
opportunity to answer that very question
themselves the ps4 the fastest cheapest
next-gen console on the market launched
two white praise from both consumers and
price even though the launch lineup was
a little flat in the exclusive
department Killzone shadow fall and
knack were the only notable ones at
retail but once you got the console
plugged into the internet and hopefully
signed up to playstation plus there were
some wonderful digital offerings like
resogun
warframe DC Universe Online Sam shapes
super motherload and trying to oh and
flower again for some reason but
moreover the PlayStation 4 is a simple
intuitive system that seems to just work
global sales burst past two million at
the start of December and judging by
availability in local stores it still
got momentum so it's fair to say 2013
was a pretty good year for PlayStation a
wealth of wonderful ps3 exclusives the
rejuvenation of the Vita and what many
consider to be the best next-gen console
available on the market roll on 2014